do you think conor mcgregor ever looks  and goes  all right mate  well that's english yeah he's from  dublin right he's like okay there you go  hold on hold on i'll get it all right  i'm ready oh top of the bone and do you  okay you think conor mcgregor was like  wait start me on a conor mcgregor accent  real quick uh wait wait he would get  i'm not here to take over i'm here to  take part okay  i got it i got it i got it i got it i  got it i got it dublin redneck pepper  she's  wouldn't mind being some  mcdonald's work  oh the clock you sound like uh you sound  like a beatles daddy the baddie oh yeah  patty the baddie and i are in the same  [ __ ] boat i identify with i identify  with fighters so often  because patty the batter is like  scousers don't get knocked out and i'm  always like i'll never quit drinking yes  one day patty and i are gonna be in a  hospital bed next to each other going  turns out this liver does give up who  the [ __ ] is that guy